Let's summarize what we've learned in the past few quizzes. We can finally fill
in the last detail of our rational zero theorem. If some polynomial, f of x
has, rational zeros, then they will be of the form x equals plus or minus a
positive factor of the constant term of f of x, over a positive factor of the
leading coefficient of f of x. Now if we call this rational zero p over q, then
p and q only have a common factor of 1. In other words, we have to write these
zeros as fractions in lowest terms, or in simplest form. So, as we saw in the
previous quiz, instead of having 2 over 6, we need to write 1 over 3 instead,
or else we'll mess up our factors. Provided that these requirements are met,
especially that p over q is in simplest terms, then q x minus p will be a
factor of f of x. You'll have plenty of opportunities to practice using the
rational zero theorem in our question section, after this lesson. Great job.